puedes escuchar mi voz alza la voz si me
puedes oír un grito de esperanza entre
la desesperación los equipos de rescate
palestinos trabajan a contrarreloj para
liberar a las personas atrapadas bajo
los escombros de un edificio residencial
uno más derribado por los recientes
ataques aéreos de israel en el séptimo
día de conflicto los bombardeos cobraron
la vida de al menos 42 civiles que de
ellos eran niños elevando el total a
casi 200 víctimas todavía se desconoce
el número de personas que están bajo los
escombros según nos han dicho las
familias y los vecinos es un gran número
y estamos trabajando aquí las cifras son
cada día más desgarradoras con más de 58
menores y 39 mujeres entre las víctimas
mortales en las calles polvo y
destrucción en el sitiado enclave donde
viven más de 2 millones de personas se
está viviendo la escalada bélica más
brutal desde 2014 cuando el ejército
israelí llevó a cabo la operación ´plomo
fundido´ la más mortífera de la historia
de gaza' sushi de 6 años se despertó
sola en el mayor hospital de gata fue
trasladada junto a su familia después de
que su hogar fuera destruido por los
ataques
corrí a ver a las niñas mi esposa salto
y abrazó a las niñas para sacarlas de la
habitación entonces un segundo ataque
aéreo golpeó la sala y sentí que los
techos estaban destruidos
yo estaba bajo los escombros los últimos
momentos de mi esposa vi que se tiró al
piso y el concreto se le vino encima de
la cabeza no pensamos que el techo y la
pared se iban a caer hoy naciones unidas
y organismos de derechos humanos
denuncian que los civiles están siendo
blanco de ataque lo que constituye un
crimen de guerra
tanto el movimiento islamista hamás como
las autoridades israelíes siguen
haciendo oídos sordos a los llamados
internacionales para un cese inmediato
de la violencia